nous avons fait une très belle campagne
une cambell une campagne digne et
respectueuse et tout d'abord je tiens à
remercier toutes celles et tous ceux qui
m'ont élu ce soir député de la première
circonscription
je mesure la responsabilité qui
m'incombe et je ferai tout pour être
digne de leur confiance
je tiens aussi à rendre hommage à
jacques pélissard pour les cinq mandats
passés comme député de notre
circonscription et je tiens à associer
cette victoire à cette victoire
toute l'équipe qui m'a accompagné en
particulier les marcheurs qui ont mis
notre circonscription en marche mais
aussi mon équipe de campagne qui a été à
mes côtés qui a fait un travail sur le
terrain formidable je vous le dis
toujours dans le respect des personnes
et de la dignité malgré les attaques que
nous avons eues aspire daniel dubois
s'est fait une place en bleu mans vous
fait dans l'esprit des bascules et une
circonscription représentée par jacques
pélissard depuis un quart de siècle
quasiment à l'assemblée nationale est-ce
que alors forcément c'est une très bonne
nouvelle pour mais ce qu'il n'y a pas un
regret dans le jura
trois circonscriptions à droite il y en
a deux qui restent à droite ce soir vous
êtes la seule députée en marche du jura
alors le mouvement en marche va
continuer bien sûr a expliqué son
programme a expliqué sa démarche
enfin moi je suis la candidate du
rassemblement sur la première
circonscription et au delà de toutes les
sensibilités je serai celle qui
additionnera toutes les énergies toutes
les intelligences des élus des citoyens
des associations des secteurs
économiques pour développer les
magnifiques atouts de notre
circonscription et pour être à l'écouté
de tous